alef Automotive is already seeing
pre-orders for its three hundred
thousand dollar Model A which is going
to be a flying car and they haven't
actually so they haven't actually
demonstrated what it looks like flying
yet but they said they're going to be
doing that and they're already getting a
whole bunch of uh pre-orders and they
hope that by 2025 they're going to have
these flying cars on the market and I
know that I've warned against flying
cars before but a bear is repeating that
this is a terrible idea like when I was
a kid like anybody else I used to dream
of the day when we had flying cars but
now but then you become a driver on the
road and you realize that this country
is plagued by terrible drivers